head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
we have the story from space.com
what is a Blood Moon published three
days ago
my friends
at 302 a.m Eastern Time
the blood moon will begin for those of
you on the west coast it will be at 1202
A.M
it's fascinating when I first heard that
a blood red moon would be happening on a
full moon on the day of the midterm
elections signifying a great red Beacon
I was like wow that's that's literally
the definition of ominous but then I
thought 3 AM though what does that mean
3 A.M that's that's not that's not
ominous at all and then I realized oh
Pacific time that means when the sun
when when the when the day starts for
the contiguous United States and
everyone is now
in November 8th the day of the midterms
the moon will turn blood red and it was
funny too because I don't know if it was
you Luke who mentioned this it's not a
blue moon yeah and there is a Blue Moon
yes it's a second full moon in the month
and we're not having that we're having a
blood moon
so the blood moon is coming and this
one's for all of you my friends because
people are referring to it as the Maga
Moon
I Google searched the spiritual meaning
of the blood moon and I would like to
read for you the opening sentence
the ancient Incans and Mesopotamians
believed the blood moon was an omen
portending death and overthrow of the
king how about that you know what is up
that's crazy and this is going to be
happening in a few hours yeah and this
is this is also the same day that a lot
of people on social media are saying
that Donald Trump will announce that
he's going to be running for president
in 2024 I'm watching his speech right
now in Dayton Ohio and there's also news
that the entire Trump family is going to
be in attendance for this news
watching I'm watching the speech now and
I'm monitoring social media but but
there's a lot of symbolism here and I
think it's fair to say that there's
going to be a lot of crazy things uh in
our social political discourse that uh
are going to be very eye-opening in the
next few hours so definitely pay
attention to what's going on here I know
I'm closely paying attention to all the
details as they're unfolding here
everyone's on their cell phones now
seeing what's going on on social media
but I'm keeping an eye on it
the crew at the post millennial who are
totally
we just gotta wait as soon as we get
word if Trump announces because he's not
going to be speaking for I told them to
message me I'm keeping an eye when's the
rally over I don't know but he's talking
forever yeah
but let's let's let me ask you guys
when you see stuff like a blood moon a
red moon right when the day starts
on the midterms when people are calling
for a red wave and The Omen is that a
blood mood signifies the the overthrow
of the king
how do you guys feel about that I think
if you believe it it's fun it's a lot of
fun you know I don't know if I believe
in
uh all of the things having some sort of
I say when you see for a universe is it
also a full moon or whatever yes so
that's going to be another major issue
because you know I I I have a lot of
friends and family that work in
emergency services and they tell me
every time it's a full moon we know it's
going to want to be a full work day we
know there's going to be a lot of people
losing their ish
um so that there is you know there's
there's a lot of things actually
verified is that true well that's what
my friends and family told me it's true
I've heard this as well yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I have but I have some family
members that are nurses some that are
police officers and they tell me like
like full moon it gets crazy it's a
simple explanation it's very bright
during a full moon yeah yeah you can go
around and do stuff that's right uh
during a new Moon I mean everybody who
lives outside of a city knows this you
don't need to but the crazy thing is
people in cities really don't get it
there's that famous story where the
power went out in LA in the 90s and
everyone started calling 9-1-1 because
there's a strange thing in the sky it
was the Milky Way they'd seen for the
first time in their lives it's crazy but
for a lot of people who live outside of
a city you know like there's Moonshadow
people in cities just it's permanent
illumination they don't even realize the
shadow yeah yeah and also you know my
friends and family reported a lot of
people just going crazy losing their
mind a lot of mental health calls a lot
of people just going absolutely berserk
and crazy so that with the the elections
with possibly Trump announcing with this
blood red moon uh with turbulence wait
wait someone super chatted uh uh a
raftus of stat said that 3am is the
witching hour
what are the statistical chances that a
Blood Moon could be on the same night as
this how often does the Blood Moon
happen it's five years yeah five every
five years
are you guys uh atheists you believe in
god what do you believe in I believe in
God I'm not I don't believe in organ any
organized religion though but it's it's
things like this I'll say
this in and of itself is not enough to
convince me of a great power beyond or
anything like that because coincidences
happen I mean people win the lottery
but what are the chances of something
like I look blood moons happen elections
happen I would love to see someone break
down the probability of the blood moon
happening at 1202 a.m Pacific
on the day of an election like we know
when our elections are going to be
they're all pre-planned it's like the
first Tuesday or whatever you know of
the month of November and then we know
when full moons are going to be because
we can track mathematically very simply
what's the probability of that occurring
you know is it going to be like one
every 17 000 years when every three
years what are five years with the blood
moon what it's certainly not because it
would happen every single time but what
if it's like really common what if it's
like actually you know every third or
fourth blood Moon's probably going to
fall on a November or Tuesday or
whatever I kind of feel like it's
extremely rare maybe somebody knows the
math I don't know I see stuff like that
not the math it's things like this that
you see enough of and eventually they're
just like there's too many weird things
like that that happen to just believe
we're in some random catech Universe
there's there's a there's some kind of
structure to all of this I I 100 think
it means something 100 but all the stuff
all the stuff combined means something I
do
blood moon there's a lot of really
really bad stuff happening in the past
couple years as you guys are aware of
but there's always a lot of really bad
stuff
there's always a lot of really it just
depends on where you're standing and
what you're looking at that I agree with
but what's been happening here is next
level it's been a while yeah Ukraine
pretty bad but it's always I mean you
guys I mean the thing is it's kind of
always like this I wish we could dig
deeper this is what humanity is we're
like we're constantly facing I think the
sad thing existential crisis we can't
even dig too deep into some of the
things going on but it's just sad I mean
there's crazy stuff happening sure but
there's all I mean there's literally
always crazy stuff the thing is right
now
so quickly that's always happening yeah
but we're I'm just trying to evaluate
what we can get into this whole thing of
like weird and inflection point in
history that Biden is always talking
about like I think it's always this nuts
when I talk to you know my grandparents
have passed but they used to talk about
all kinds of crazy things happening like
they had World War II they had the
Holocaust for goodness sakes they had
the Great Depression my grandfather was
like mucking around in the woods of
Billerica Massachusetts to forage from
mushrooms to feed his family and by the
time he was an older man like if he
looked at a mushroom he would Wretch
like stuff is always nuts let me read
this let me read this in the Western
Christian tradition the hour between 3
A.M and 4 a.m was considered a period of
peak Supernatural activity this time is
also referred to as the devil's hour due
to it being a mocking inversion of time
in which Jesus supposedly died which is
3 pm
right that's like the whole reverse like
everything in scripture it's reversed in
order to make it uh satanic you have
like the black mass that happens you
know in the middle of the night and all
of this stuff but also in um you know in
ye olden times that's when people would
wake up because they would go to bed
after it got dark and then they would
kind of wake up in the middle of the
night correct and do stuff and then go
back to bed what does the omen portend
will it does it mean that at some point
in the next three years I saw so it's
not I don't think it was every five
years I think that's on average I'm not
sure I was reading a couple articles but
I think uh yeah the blood moon the blood
moon might be once every five but
there's going to be another total lunar
eclipse three years later
so we have this blood moon in the way
this three-year period maybe it's
meaningless I don't know all I can think
is that song you remember that song
Total Eclipse of the Heart yep that's
all I can think of right now it's
running through my head so I think it's
a lot of fun I don't know that I put a
lot of stock in all of the various you
know poor tents or whatever like that
but I do think that it makes it a little
bit extra exciting to think about
so here's what here's what let's let's
just we'll get some science here they
say a Blood Moon that happens when
Earth's moon is in a total lunar eclipse
while it while it has no special
astronomical significance the view in
the sky is striking as the usually
whitish Moon becomes red or Ruddy Brown
lunar eclipses can only happen during a
full moon when the sun fully illuminates
the surface usually a full moon has no
Eclipse because the moon orbits in a
slightly different plane than the Earth
and the Sun however at times the planes
coincide Earth passes in between the
Moon and the Sun and cuts off sunlight
causing an eclipse so what is a what
makes it red
during a full eclipse the Moon is an
Earth's Shadow blah blah blah a red moon
appears can depend on how much pollution
is that what it is
is it just pollution blood moon calendar
okay here we go so there was actually
another one this year 16th of May
anything happen on May 16th
I don't recall November 8th the next
will be March uh 14 2025.
and then September 7th 2025 and then
March 3rd 2026.
I don't know I'll check in my date book
just just the one day it lines up huh so
that's the thing like what's the
likelihood of this Blood mood lining up
on election day and a time when people
are calling for a red wave and expecting
Republicans to win and
Well it can't be uh it says in the
bottom right there it can't be anything
but pollution because Christopher
Columbus used it apparently back in the
day yeah so I guess they're saying
pollution makes it look more red uh okay
I understand yeah I don't know I don't
remember anything on those dates at all
May 16th I came on the I was I was on
your show two days later oh man that's
real bad news right I mean you're you're
going to be doing all the chaos right it
was all my fault
so we have this video basically
explaining it Los Angeles
before the moon sets we actually uh
where we are it looks like the moon's
gonna go in an arc over the mountains so
we'll be able to like track it we're
gonna try and film it see if we can get
it it's crazy I remember you know
sometimes I I remember seeing several
Blood Moons throughout my life and just
not even realizing it was like what it
was or what was going on it's like oh
blood moon I didn't realize that was
today you just look with the moon and
it's terrifying yeah pretty scary
so so what do you think I was getting
overthrown yeah I mean
I I I I hope the people in charge uh but
only time will tell about it being in
charge they're terrible at it well I
don't know yeah I think I think it all
depends on perspective some would say
what they're doing is absolute genius
because they kind of make excuses and
they make it make it look like uh an old
man who's who's not really well is
really in charge of everything when in
reality I don't think that's the case at
all but I was gonna throw it at you Owen
because you were talking about um you
know do you believe in god what about
you what do you believe in I do and the
thing is that as you're on your journey
I think that you'll see these things
that'll come up in your field of
experience that are like one in millions
and you'll see this again and again and
again as you keep down that path you'll
see this repeatedly and you'll question
it because you're like this is
impossible how could this be and I've
just seen too much of this as I've
gotten older it just it's it's uh I
don't even like talking about it I feel
like it cheapens it it's just one of
those things that you'll experience like
even when you were saying um
like there I almost don't even want to
pipe in because I feel like
there's just certain things that happen
that cheapens it if you go too deep into
it but there's just certain coincidences
that are so intense and so crazy as you
move on and um I think this is one of
them you know I I think things are
happening now personally so we'll see
let's let's look back in a couple years
I think that human beings have a
propensity to feel like they are at the
Pinnacle of history and are at the end
of human existence I thought you made a
great point about the Holocaust and all
these other terrible things happen I
thought you had a great point there yeah
I did I I can make more of them we like
to find patterns and things yeah yeah
part of what we do
yeah but then some of these things as
you're on your journey will be these one
in a million coincidences that let you
do things that are so unbelievable and
so it's one of these things where
um you'll become more like I would
encourage you just to even continue to
look for these things I think that
you're on a great journey I think you'll
see them if you look all right man
thanks sounds like a good real serious
but uh just keep robbing
how many of you bought Powerball tickets
is it I meant to but I didn't realize I
had to do it 2.9 billion yeah 11 pm is
when they're doing the drawing
my friend asked me to get one and I I
didn't didn't someone say that that the
lottery is pretty much a tax on the poor
yeah
and like the money goes to the state uh
we were talking about this yesterday I'm
like you know if I win the lottery how
much of that money actually goes to me
how much of it goes to the state how
would I feel knowing that I'm giving so
much of that money to the state thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time